music teacher in Michigan has caused a
big controversy because she removed the
word gay from the Christmas song deck
the halls'
is the same thing that really happened
yeah now a lot of people think that this
was a ridiculous overreaction on the
teachers part but apparently she's not
the only one concerned about this issue
check out this new product that's coming
out for the holiday season Don we now
our gay apparel what am I in a San
Francisco bathhouse your wish you can
enjoy all the holiday classics without
hearing all the gay stuff well now you
can with this no collection straight-up
Christmas it's a great CD full of all
the holiday songs you love but we've
changed all the [ __ ] lyrics so you and
your buddies can finally listen to
Christmas songs without worrying about
turning queer you'll get all the DJed
hits like rudolph the red state reindeer
little drummer boy the whom i'm not
sexually attracted chest vaginas
roasting on an open fire
silent night of sitting at a bar
watching football Santa Claus is coming
to town for the UFC fight jingle breast
I saw Mommy Kissing Santa Claus as God
intended
police Nobby dude Oh kick-ass Steel town
of Bethlehem Pennsylvania the 12 days of
Christmas - the part about Lords
a-leaping those 40 sleigh bells
deck the halls and then to you Nancy
boys checking out my ass grandma got run
over by a reindeer that was sent by God
to punish her for attending a gay
wedding
hear what I hear yes monster trucks Jeff
to the world and many more plus if you
order now you'll get this bonus CD
high-powered holidays featuring all your
favorite holiday songs performed on
power tools like the classic tune deck
the halls' played on a Dewalt 18 volt
XRP cordless power drill
nothing gay about that check out how to
order your CDs now header oh ho ho and
happy holidays you got it
okay let's do this with bonus high power
of a CD for this $19.99 order online and
straight up Christmas gay it was the
only domain available